Now this works, technically, but there's a problem. What if we have a dozen
types of entities that we might need to spawn, or, 50, or even 100. Real time
strategy games for instance contain many different entity definitions. Writing
out a spawn entity function to represent all of these items would involve a
large case statement that wouldn't really scale well for programmer maintenance
over time. For instance, if a designer wanted to add a new type of entity,
they'd actually need a programmer's help to do it, to go in and add a specific
line of code for that entity type. The problem is further visible if you
consider code maintenance. Adding reference to class definition throughout your
code basis is just asking for problems. To address this issue, we're going to
take advantage of an interesting property in JavaScript. Namely, that we can
create a new object given a handle to its definition. To allow this, each
overloaded entity definition will update a hash table with a pointer to its
class definition. Once we have a hash table entry between the string name of
the instance class, we can then use this instance to create a new version of
that class. Remember that in grids, map development is done through a program
called Tiled which allows our content creators to place objects in the world,
and set their type via a string. This means the data that we'll be receiving
from our map definition file, is a list of objects with a string property
representing their class type. Our code needs to be able to react to this by
using the hash table that maps these string values to the class definitions
they represent. What this means is this previous definition of spawnEntity
function needs to be replaced with a nice healthy reference to this factory
object, and use it as we've defined.